the war is on the enemy is attacking on
American soil our armed forces will take
care of the human invaders but there is
another enemy a file destroyer of
property homes and lives we must fight
in every American community and it's
everybody's fight let us look more
closely into the rubble left by this
explosion there there he is our enemy of
the racket he's about as loathsome a
creature as we know the bottom word in
anybody's language look at that wicked
countenance who the mere sight of it
gives you goose flesh this natural
abhorrence of rats is as old as man
himself and for these reasons they do
tremendous damage to our buildings
knowing holes weakening structures
ruining plumbing and starting fires they
ruin large quantities of food and other
supplies destroying ten times as much as
they eat and polluting great quantities
more that might have been eaten by human
beings and most important they carry
diseases including the dread plague and
typhus fever sometimes the disease germs
are carried on the rats feet
but more often the infection is spread
by secondary parasites like lice and
fleas the infected flea leaves a sick or
dead rat attaches himself to a live
healthy one and is thus taken into the
rat's nest we're pleased lived and breed
abundantly infected fleas of em carried
from the nest into your home or the
place you work or shop or a visit where
they are knocked off by the rats
scratching they hop around on the floor
until time for the next meal you provide
this next meal and you become infected
through the brick in your skin where the
bite occurs it is the close association
of rats and men living together which
constitutes a health menace prevent this
association and you break the chain of
infection the rat is by far our most
costly mammalian pests and the most
dangerous animal enemy of man in the
United States there are more rats than
human inhabitants it costs approximately
two dollars a year to feed one rat and
the estimated annual board deal in this
country alone is well over 300 million
dollars a rather high figure for an
unwelcome guest especially in times like
these you might well ask why do we pay
for it
public health officials know how to get
rid of rat and the story can be told in
three short line lock their entrance
into buildings eliminate enclosed spaces
where they nest catch and kill it is
always better to know the enemy before
we begin to fight by studying his habits
and needs we discover the weak points of
his defense and then we can strike where
it will do most good for example rats
hug the wall when climbing stairs so we
catch them with traps placed near the
wall
Raptors like these are no barrier to a
rat's progress but on them
he leaves his mark we recognize the
signs and placed traps in the way we
know that rats eat meat grain vegetables
garbage almost anything and they will do
seemingly impossible things in order to
get at food take this fellow for
instance gnawing through a lead pipe and
here is as good an exhibition of wire
walking as you've ever seen at the
circus
this rat knows that the wire leads to
food
after he gets to the building he must
find an opening into the house the
instinct to nest and reproduce is as
strong as the instinct to eat so rats
naturally seek a home usually they don't
have to go to much trouble to find homes
because we provide these for the
made-to-order steam-heated
everything but the welcome mat these are
typical examples of conditions and
factors responsible for the presence of
rats in our buildings and don't think
they're necessarily slum dwellers they
will live in any building that provides
harborage even homes like this we know
that rats are very prolific producing
litters of five to ten every couple of
months according to estimates of the
United States Fish and Wildlife Service
they are the most prolific of all
mammals and a single pair of rats left
to reproduce unhampered what become
1,500 in a year and 360 million in the
short space of three years of course
they're not allowed to multiply
unhampered so the situation is not quite
so bad it's plenty bad enough however
and high time we took the offensive and
counter-attack here are a few of the
things you can do get rid of old rubbish
eliminate enclosed spaces in which rats
might nests under platforms under stairs
under houses closed openings around
pipes and wires or better still make
such openings to fit exactly the pipes
they admit and put metal collars around
them to prevent breaks or annoying rats
will not burrow in the ground deeper
than 20 inches so make the foundations
of your buildings rat proof 2 feet below
and 1 foot above ground
concrete or a metal sheet sunk along the
building wall
we'll serve this purpose avoid double
walls where possible but if you use them
be sure they are kept intact so rats
cannot run between them blocks and jams
help cover basement windows and other
openings with wire mesh or perforated
sheet steel any opening larger than half
an inch will admit rats if you can get
your forefinger into it a rat can
squeeze through wear wire mesh or
glasses use it must be protected and
kept intact once broken your protection
is gone wherever possible use rat proof
materials metal concrete plaster stone
bricks or tile this door is flashed with
metal and the door pull keeps it closed
when not in use concrete is the most
nearly perfect material for rat proofing
repair breaks in walls as soon as they
are discovered in order to keep them out
buildings where food is kept must be
unusually well protected like this one
with concrete floor
brick walls and tight-fitting metal door
finally there should be a periodic
inspections to see that buildings are
properly maintained by traps with
knowledge ask your health department for
help
Rep control is up to you
while individual airport can do a lot
they concerted effort of a whole
community is needed to solve the problem
completely eternal vigilance and they
will plan continuing program should be
our answer to this challenge
solo wrapped the outlook for you is not
very good
keep them out